Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here.
I've just seen X-Men: Apocalypse and can confirm
there's a single post-credits scene right
at the very end of the movie's credits.
In this video, I'm going to break down and
explain what's in the scene and what it means
for future X-Men movies, so there will be
spoilers.
If you want to avoid any spoilers, click here
for my spoiler-free review or come back after
you've seen the movie.
The post-credits scene begins with a small
group of men in black suits walking through
the corridors of the Weapon X facility while
a clean-up operation is in progress.
Blood and bodies are being cleared from the
floor and bullets are also being vacuumed
up.
One of the suited men who wears glasses also
carries a briefcase and he uses a key card
to enter one of the labs where we see x-rays
of a body and skulls, reminiscent of the x-rays
from the Alkali Lake facility that first appeared
in the second X-Men movie.
In the lab, the suited man takes a vial of
dark red liquid labelled "Weapon X", which
is likely a sample of Wolverine's blood, and
he puts it in his briefcase which has at least
3 other vials in it each with different coloured
liquids.
The colours in the other vials are green,
yellow and there's another with an almost
clear liquid.
As the man closes the briefcase, we see a
large chrome label with the words "Essex Corp".
The name Essex is a huge tease for the comic
book villain Mr Sinister, also known as Dr
Nathanial Essex.
In the comics, Nathanial Essex is a Darwinist
geneticist obsessed with developing a superior
species.
He shares an outlook with Apocalypse that
only the strongest should survive and he actually
works with him after Apocalypse turns him
into Mr Sinister, which is the last word his
wife said to him on her death bed.
In the comics, Sinister has a history of collecting
genetic material from mutants, and in the
Weapon X comics he surreptitiously collected
a vial of blood from Marvel's first mutant
Namor when he was injured by the Nazis during
World War 2.
Sinister then used Namor's blood for his experiments,
creating a clone of Namor that he tried out
against Captain America.
So, if that is indeed Wolverine's blood in
the vial in X-Men: Apocalypse, that could
be a big hint that we'll see the female Wolverine
clone X-23 appear in Wolverine 3.
Producer Simon Kinberg has already pitched
a female Wolverine character to Fox and Hugh
Jackman has said the next Wolverine solo movie
will be his last.
Cloning X-23 from Wolverine's genetic material
could be an interesting way to introduce an
alternate version of one of Fox's most popular
mutants to date.
By the way, Deadpool director Tim Miller has
said he'd love to see Deadpool fight X-23.
And what about those other vials in the briefcase?
Well, Wolverine 3 casting has confirmed we're
getting Richard E. Grant as a "villainous
mad-scientist type" so he could be the movie
version of Doctor Abraham Cornelius, a Weapon
X scientist working on replicating Wolverine
and other mutants' powers in the comics.
If Mr Sinister has been able to collect genetic
material from any of the other X-Men who were
trapped at Stryker's Weapon X building, it's
always possible we'd see clones of them in
future films.
And if he has any of Jean Grey's genes he
could create her clone Madelyne Pryor, which
he creates in the comics.
Cable, who's the child of Cyclops and Madelyne
Prior, is confirmed as appearing in Deadpool
2, so we could see Sinister involved in Cable's
origin story.
Mr Sinister is a major villain in the X-Men
comics and Simon Kinberg has said that he
could show up in the Gambit movie as well
as the X-Men films.
In the comics, Remy LeBeau has a history of
working with Dr Essex as an agent of his,
so assuming the Gambit solo movie does get
made, it looks likely Mr Sinister will pop
up there.
I think Mr Sinister could be used to build
up a more unified X-Men movie universe in
a similar way to how Marvel Studios have used
Thanos to tie together its different superheroes
and villains and build them towards Infinity
War.
So guys, what did you think about the post-credits
tease for Mr Sinister and who would you like
to see cast as the villain?
Bryan Cranston already said he'd really like
to play Mr Sinister at New York Comic Con
last year, so do you think he'd be a good
choice?
Just to let you know, coming up I'll have
a cool giveaway for 2 sets of official Fox
X-Men: Apocalypse merchandise on my upcoming
Apocalypse videos.
So, make sure you're subscribed for my full
movie easter egg guide and more breakdowns
of the movie coming shortly.
And to check out more of those videos, click
right for my full X-Men: Apocalypse playlist
with my movie review, easter egg guide and
breakdowns, and click left for my Captain
America Civil War post-credits breakdown and
easter egg videos.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to subscribe,
share and like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!